do we go to the sandbags or do we put
our trust in the Europeans well you know
it's interesting that you mentioned that
because last night's run at the gfs
model at 0z trended further east and
that's what allowed the Hurricane Center
to go with that long-range track south
of New York City the interesting thing
is the 6e gfs has come in and it is
further east and it looks an awful lot
like the track of the European so the
trend now is East it's got the storm
southeast of Nantucket Monday night
early Tuesday morning so what we do with
these bottles is we watch the trend in
the guidance and if they continue the
trend towards the European as you
mentioned it correctly forecast at
sandys left turn days and days in
advance of the u.s. guidance it may
again be hitting another home run saying
that joaquim never heads towards the
United States but gets kicked out to sea
and stays away from the coast so we're
going to be watching the twelves Iran of
the gfs very very carefully around
noontime today I should mention the GFS
that's the the US model exactly there
are doesn't a system but the the
European in the US the British and
Canadians pretty much the best out there
even if the storm goes out to sea the
forecast is for rain from basically
washington DC up through the Cape Cod
area that's correct and it's due to a
fraud a stalled frontal system which
pushed through yesterday that's fronts
now is being held up by the Bermuda high
out in the Atlantic and it's actually
going to be pushed back towards us as we
get closer to the weekend so the rain
that moved through the area yesterday i
stalled out in Virginia more of that's
going to come up at us over the weekend
and we're likely to see a rain whether
or not Joaquin comes up the coaster goes
out to see we're still going to get more
rain as we head right through Saturday
and into Sunday all right I know Rob
Carolyn will be watching us for us
Joaquin very closely and we'll keep
checking back with him will let you know
if you need to get the slicker out